hey reject nation Greg Albie here and
I'm John we are gonna be catching up on
some III trailers here got several
guests scheduled over the next few days
everyone's on a different schedule for
us we want to keep it with people who
are familiar with a lot of these
franchises already people who are much
more informed than us however there's a
game trailer out that got a lot of
requests that's brand-new so we could
talk about this one cyberpunk 2077 or
2077 or I don't care how to say a brand
new game I'm excited to check it out
before we go into this I wanted to give
an announcement I mentioned this with a
couple videos with Stacy Howard already
John and I are gonna be hosting our very
first ever live event that's like a
hybrid of a special show plus a meet and
greet at Reena Sinha lounge on Sunset
Boulevard keep a look at on our social
media for official post and we're to get
tickets and everything tickets will be
very cheap don't worry we want to hang
out with you guys before and after in
during the show what we're gonna be
doing for the show it's gonna be like a
live film therapy event if you've ever
seen Brianne Chandler's miss movie
segment she's actually gonna be
monitoring the questions for us on July
7 it's gonna be a live film therapy
event where basically she asks us
questions about how certain films have
affected our lives and we'll be playing
clips on the screen over there because
it's at a movie theater you know we're
gonna get better at communicating
exactly how this works it's gonna be a
fun interactive segment we're gonna get
questions from the audience and then the
questions Briana has prepared for us
will allow us to play certain clips to
be able to screen it on the big screen
that they have the arena so now it's
gonna be a lot of fun guys we're excited
to be holding the event too because it's
gonna be a small event we don't want it
to be like some massive thing into the
theater only fits about 50 people like
it's a really nice screen but the the
seating is only 50 people for the first
50 to get tickets are gonna be able to
come to this recommend pack them in
people be July 7th that is a Saturday
hope to see you there
[Music]
nice 77 they voted my city the worst
place to live in America main issues sky
high rate of violence and more people
living below the poverty line than
anywhere else can't deny it it's all
true and everybody still wants to live
here
the Seas always got a promise for you
you lie it's there just wear what keeps
you going
I don't know
Oh Sin Eater yes and I'm a big dreamer
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
they got that domain switch that looks
wicked
though it's crazy man that reminds me of
all kinds of awesome futuristic set
movies that have an addiction to
technology advancements and getting way
out of hand when and like the criminal
underworld is overruling a lot I don't
have that Blade Runner ghost in the
shell yeah later on I thought I'd goes
to the shots on a ready player one I
thought of like élisa élisa most yeah is
he looking like mercenary types some
elements of a Robocop except not as
dirty or grungy yeah
cyberpunk look kind of has a little bit
of a dread divide a hint of terminator
cyberpunk just a hint maybe because I'm
just thinking of Bill Paxton in the
first one okay I'm ready player one with
his VR moans look ripped right out of
that but I mean and ready player one is
ripped just right out of other stuff
yeah just the aesthetics of this game
alone I mean cyberpunk is such a cool
aesthetic genre to see not only just all
these mods all these different like
punky yeah there's like it really does
look like those inner-city waste lands
that you would see in like an 80s movie
yeah ramped up with all the sci-fi or
what the gameplay is gonna be like on
this because it's mostly like a
cinematic trailer oh this is a game yeah
yeah I thought it was a movie we're
watching babies I heard this takes place
in California her night city is like a
fictional spot of California well you
never get enough games to take place in
California clearly people think we're in
highly of our state with the Yankees and
with a kind of technology game this is
and this is I'm assuming open-world if
it's an open world game I imagine it's
one of those games where you can create
a character just from scratch I mean you
even see a lot of like artificial
intelligence elements in here so I'm
imagining that you can't create a
character and I love when games allow
you to do that it just seems like the
the most awesome world to be a part will
probably be a great online video game to
play well in Israel a video game can get
you excited just to explore the world
and go on side questions yeah like stuff
that distracts from the main plot or
whatever cuz i almost got like a really
future Eve Grand Theft Auto kind of
Bible definitely I'm like almost done
with the first redhead redemption right
now that's
my favorite things is like just going on
those random side quests all the time
like ah screw the main storyline for now
playing Fallout 3 like I could never
resume like helping yeah samba guy why
not yeah man this game looks sweet it
looks really awesome I can't wait to
pick it up and hope you get a gameplay
trailer soon because it's really easy to
get sucked in with awesome cinematic
trailer footage yeah we're gonna have to
invest in xbox one or a ps4 so we have
you yeah yeah that's right I will
contribute that alright guys we'll leave
your comments down because we were going
off of the most requested over the
guests that we have scheduled over the
next few days so keep a lookout I know
for sure I'm gonna be on top of the last
of us part 2 because I've actually beat
the first one you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell check us out on patreon full-length
TV show reactions weekly Q&A is music
video coverage get tickets to arena
Cinna lounge July 7th John Humphrey and
I will be there Brienne Chandler Stacy
Howard trying to get some more people to
come out and make an appearance too but
it'll be a ton a ton of fun